well did you did you see the news with
all's fighting
mazdale's fighting usman
and i can't [ __ ] wait when is he
fighting
uh usman well it sounds like you can
wait because you have no idea when
they're fighting
so when are they fighting saturday
are they fighting this saturday sounds
like you can definitely wait because you
have no idea
when they're fighting well that makes me
very happy
you put all your money on who i want to
put money on anybody
just because it's a it's a fight i want
to put any money on
fights yeah
um it's just going to be a wrestler
against
[ __ ] striker right yeah
i mean yeah i mean no no
no no no no no you did nothing on your
birthday
uh i did actually i went and took a car
ride to
laguna beach just to kind of see the
outside without interacting with someone
i forced my sister to drive me
everywhere that day
oh your sister was your little uber
driver yeah
it's great i haven't had to drive since
she's moved in so i'm just kind of
forcing her to do all the [ __ ] that i
don't want to do
and she's well she's not in school right
now because there's no school anywhere
she graduated uh this year actually
from high school ohio state oh hi
yeah hey hey this is awesome
yeah this is awesome this is awesome but
i wanted to talk a little bit more about
usman
and mazvidal i appreciate that
i don't you just asked me it's a
wrestler versus striker well well in a
lot of ways it is
in a lot of ways you've got a much
better wrestler fighting a much better
striker
and that's that's a fair comparison now
you have us doesn't seem to get tired he
doesn't gas
i haven't seen i haven't seen cardio be
an issue with maswan
is physically he just seems so [ __ ]
huge
compared to any 170 pounder yeah he's
bigger for sure
so the question is i don't know man it's
going to be really interesting
the whole card's stacked i can't wait
who else is on the card
i'll pull it up yeah man jim i don't
think they updated the main event
yet for whatever reason on ufc.com oh
they did
did they i think so let's see
they didn't this morning when we were
doing below the belt there they go they
finally do
they did it finally
main card
that's a good fight so that whole the
whole thing about max holloway having
weight issues was fake
that was fake yeah that's from a troll
account
[ __ ] peter yan jose aldo
whoa rose gets to fight jessica again
holy [ __ ] i can't wait
haven't seen i haven't heard from
patreon then in a while yep
yeah the whole card stacked
it was gonna be great
i [ __ ] thought desmer went to a
different fight me
who was the man uh vulcan yeah i thought
he went to a different fight league for
some reason
no
[Music]
there you go yeah
hopefully we'll be able to do a
companion for that because usually we
just do fight nights and that that's a
stacked pay-per-view
yeah no [ __ ] could that be really good
and then you're only going to get
mozzarella tomorrow if they both
passed their kobetes once they arrive on
fight island too
oh is that right they have to take it
here and then they have to fly there and
take it again
i'm gonna tell you this right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh okay what's gonna
happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing